hello chase right y'all doing great jump
into all the things I need to talk to
you about the last time you were here I
said to you you need to take someone
from The Bachelor lo and behold everyone
heard me and everyone from The Bachelor
started following you on Instagram so
you're welcome on Instagram mate who
should I date from The Bachelor well I
would have suggested Lauren Bushnell
cause she's my favorite but Chris Lane
just scooped her up so I wouldn't maybe
suggest like a like a Becca Chile
perhaps perhaps
do you follow her do you know her work
making matches how are you doing this is
how many CNAs for you now just like not
even fazed by all the glitz in the glam
no especially not tonight cuz it's like
I'm actually gonna dive into what y'all
got buried the lede yeah no Jack Daniels
but no um when you taste it when I drink
tequila baby Jaxen there are you rooting
for them tonight they're hilarious man
if you ever get another you know you've
you've done interviews with those guys
we have I don't really have any
favorites for anything I mean most these
people are good people like it Michael
Ray was up for an award with anyone must
be nice not that I know of
they may have beef with me but I don't
well this would be a good time to tell
you about some beef we heard okay next
okay we'll give you a whole list but we
have to say it off camera cuz it's so
controversial this is the morning toast
take a shot who are you toasting - what
are you tossing - I'm toasting to the
fact that I don't have anything to do
after this and I get a drink it was hell
yeah that's a committed
you